en el vídeo anterior vimos los pasos
para dibujar estructuras de puntos de
lewis en este vídeo usaremos esos pasos
para dibujar algunas estructuras y
veremos cómo se relaciona la carga forma
en un momento analizamos esta definición
dibujemos rápidamente la estructura de
puntos de louis para el cat ión amonio
nh4 + primero vamos a calcular el número
total de electrones de valencia si usa
en la tabla periódica encontrarán que el
nitrógeno se encuentra en el grupo 5 así
que tiene 5 electrones de valencia y el
hidrógeno tiene 1 pero como tenemos 4
hidrógenos 5 + 4 es igual a 9 electrones
y como tenemos esta carga positiva
eso significa que perdemos un electrón
en total tenemos
y ocho electrones de valencia ahora el
nitrógeno es nuestro átomo central
porque es el menos electro negativo sin
tomar en cuenta al hidrógeno entonces
tenemos al nitrógeno unido a cuatro
átomos de hidrógeno hasta ahora ya
colocamos 2 468 electrones ya colocamos
todos los electrones de valencia esta es
nuestra estructura y podemos ponerla
entre corchetes para señalar la carga
positiva ahora para calcular las cargas
formales voy a redibujar la estructura
sabemos que cada enlace covalente
consiste en dos electrones tenemos 2
electrones en cada enlace y para
calcular la carga formal del nitrógeno
sabemos que el átomo libre se encuentra
en el grupo 5 de la tabla periódica
5 electrones de valencia y a esto le
restamos el número de electrones de
valencia que hay alrededor del átomo en
la molécula entonces si analizamos
nuestra estructura observen que uno de
los electrones del enlace está más cerca
del hidrógeno y el otro está más cerca
del nitrógeno así que alrededor del
nitrógeno tenemos cuatro electrones de
valencia entonces 5 menos 4 es igual a
más 1 tenemos una carga formal positiva
en el nitrógeno este cálculo fue para el
nitrógeno ahora vamos con los hidrógenos
para el hidrógeno el hidrógeno se
encuentra en el grupo 1 de la tabla
periódica así que tenemos un electrón de
valencia en el átomo libre y a esto le
restamos los electrones de valencia que
tiene a su alrededor en la molécula
observen que cada hidrógeno está rodeado
por un electrón de valencia así que uno
menos uno es igual a cero tenemos una
carga formal igual a cero en todos los
hidrógenos de nuestro catión amonio así
es como podemos calcular las cargas
formales ahora veamos cómo las cargas
formales pueden afectar la estructura
final
aquí tenemos ácido sulfúrico el primer
paso es calcular el número total de
electrones de valencia entonces cada
hidrógeno tiene uno y tenemos dos
hidrógenos el azufre se encuentra en el
grupo 6 de la tabla periódica así que
tiene 6 electrones de valencia y el
oxígeno también se encuentra en el grupo
6 pero como tenemos 4 6 por 4 es igual a
24 entonces 24 más
630 + 2 tenemos 32 electrones de
valencia en total en el ácido sulfúrico
ahora hay que definir quién es el átomo
central sin tomar en cuenta el nitrógeno
podría ser el azufre o el oxígeno si usa
en la tabla periódica encontrarán que el
oxígeno es más electro negativo que el
azufre así que nuestro átomo central es
el azufre y está unido a 4 átomos de
oxígeno y después tenemos dos hidrógenos
unidos a dos átomos de oxígeno
tenemos un ácido veamos cuántos
electrones de valencia ya colocamos aquí
tenemos 2 468 10
y 12 entonces 32 menos 12 aún nos falta
colocar 20 electrones de valencia y
recuerden que en el siguiente paso
podemos empezar a colocarlos en nuestros
átomos terminales pero no los pondremos
en el nitrógeno porque los hidrógenos ya
están rodeados por dos electrones así
que colocaremos algunos electrones en
los oxígenos como el oxígeno cumple con
la regla del octeto analicemos el
oxígeno de arriba observen que este
oxígeno ya está rodeado por dos
electrones así que para completar su
objeto necesita 6 electrones más 1 2 3 4
5 6 y lo mismo ocurre con el oxígeno de
abajo
ahora para los oxígenos de los lados
observen que el oxígeno de la izquierda
ya tiene 24 electrones a su alrededor y
para completar su octeto solo necesita 4
electrones más así que agregamos dos
pares de electrones libres y podemos
hacer lo mismo con este oxígeno de la
derecha muy bien veamos cuántos
electrones agregamos colocamos 6 en el
oxígeno de arriba 6 en el oxígeno de
abajo llevamos 12 y después colocamos 4
en el de la derecha y 4 en el de la
izquierda entonces 12 + 8 es igual a 20
ya colocamos todos los electrones de
valencia supongamos que ésta es nuestra
estructura ya tenemos un octeto
alrededor del azufre también alrededor
de los oxígenos y los hidrógenos están
felices
todo parece indicar que hemos terminado
sin embargo calculemos las cargas
formales
recuerden que cada enlace covalente
consiste en dos electrones entonces
calculemos la carga forman t el oxígeno
de arriba en este enlace uno de los
electrones está más cerca del oxígeno y
el otro está más cerca del azufre
entonces el oxígeno está rodeado por 7
electrones ahora en el átomo libre el
oxígeno tiene 6 electrones de valencia 6
menos 7 es igual a menos 1 y el oxígeno
de arriba tiene una carga formal de
menos 1 y el oxígeno de abajo también
tiene una carga formal de menos 1 ahora
analicemos el azufre
sabemos que el azufre se encuentra en el
grupo 6 de la tabla periódica
y que el átomo libre tiene 6 electrones
de valencia pero en la molécula este
electrón está más cerca del azufre
también este y estos electrones así que
el azufre está rodeado por 4 electrones
y 6 menos 4 es igual a más 2 entonces
parecía que habíamos terminado pero
tenemos muchas cargas formales menos uno
más dos y menos uno y en la realidad las
moléculas tienden a minimizar las cargas
formales
entonces re dibujemos rápidamente la
estructura y veamos si podemos mover
algunos electrones para minimizar las
cargas formales no podemos agregar más
electrones porque ya colocamos todos los
32 electrones de valencia que calculamos
en total así que lo único que podemos
hacer es compartir algunos electrones si
tomamos este par de él
acronis del oxígeno de arriba y los
movemos hacia acá y también tomamos este
par de electrones y los movemos hacia
acá para formar un doble enlace
dibujemos como nos queda la estructura y
calculemos nuevamente las cargas
formales ahora tenemos al azufre unido
con un doble enlace al oxígeno de arriba
y con otro doble enlace al oxígeno de
abajo el oxígeno de arriba ahora tiene
dos pares de electrones libres al igual
que el oxígeno de abajo del lado
izquierdo todo permanece igual tenemos
un bache y también tenemos un h del lado
derecho ok ahora analicemos las cargas
formales recuerde cada enlace consiste
en dos electrones entonces primero
calculemos la carga formal del oxígeno
de arriba
el oxígeno libre tiene 6 electrones de
valencia y en la molécula podemos ver
que tiene 6 electrones a su alrededor
entonces 6 menos 6 es igual a 0 el
oxígeno de arriba ya tiene una carga
formal igual a 0 y lo mismo ocurre con
el oxígeno de abajo ahora analicemos el
azufre el átomo libre tiene 6 electrones
de valencia y observen que en la
molécula el azufre está rodeado por 6
electrones entonces 6 menos 6 es igual a
0 y si calculamos la carga formal de
alguno de los oxígenos de los lados por
ejemplo el de la derecha
alrededor de este átomo de oxígeno
tenemos 6 electrones en total y 6 menos
6 es igual a cero así que esta
estructura ya tiene cargas formales
igual a cero
esta es la estructura correcta
finalmente hablemos de los objetos
sabemos que los hidrógenos están felices
rodeados por dos electrones los oxígenos
están felices porque todos tienen su
octeto y en este caso el azufre ha
excedido su octeto pero no hay problema
porque se encuentra en el periodo 3 de
la tabla periódica y hablamos sobre eso
en el vídeo anterior entonces esto es
algo más que debemos tomar en cuenta al
dibujar estructuras de puntos de lewis a
veces las cargas formales pueden afectar
la estructura final de la molécula oyón